c'est une attaque qui complexifie encore
un peu plus les négociations sur le
nucléaire iranien alors que des
discussions ont repris la semaine
dernière à vienne en présence des
etats-unis l'iran accuse israël de
vouloir faire échouer le processus avec
cette action le régime sioniste a bien
sûr essayer de se venger du peuple
iranien pour la patience et la sagesse
dont il a fait preuve en attendant la
levée des sanctions
la réponse de l'iran sera la vengeance
sur le régime sioniste au bon endroit et
au bon moment les accusations iraniennes
surviennent en pleine visite du
secrétaire d'état à la défense américain
à jérusalem
ignorant les affirmations de téhéran le
premier ministre de l'état hébreu a de
nouveau désigné la république islamique
comme la principale menace pour son pays
au nom des états unis lloyd austin lui a
tout de suite apporté son soutien au
moyen-orient aucune menace n'est plus
grave plus dangereuse plus pressante que
celles posées par le régime fanatique
d'iran que l'iran continue à soutenir
les terroristes à travers le monde sur
les cinq continents menace on part tous
les civils les liens étroits et solide
que nous entretenons avec israël sont
essentielles à la stabilité à la
sécurité régionale du moyen-orient et
nous sommes tous d'accord sur le fait
que nous devons continuer à travailler
en étroite collaboration pour renforcer
le partenariat stratégique entre les
etats-unis et israël
de son côté l'union européenne demande
des clarifications sur l'incident de
natanz moscou dit lui espérer que ces
négociations ne seront pas sapé par cet
événement cette attaque contre un site
nucléaire iranien survient à un moment
crucial alors que joe biden s'est
déclaré prêt à revenir sur le retrait
américain de l'accord de vienne
en contrepartie washington demande à
téhéran de respecter ses engagements sur
la limitation de son programme nucléaire
mais pour le moment les positions des
deux pays demeurent très éloignées
l'iran exige comme préalable la levée de
toutes les sanctions américaines
imposées par l'administration trump en
conséquence les pourparlers se déroulent
pour l'instant de manière cloisonnée
il n'y a pas encore de discussions
directes entre américains et iraniens
ces derniers mènent des pourparlers avec
la chine la russie la france le royaume
uni l'allemagne et l'ue et l'union
européenne qui joue les intermédiaires
entre téhéran et washington
le processus pourrait durer plusieurs
semaines selon des diplomates proches
des négociations des discussions jugée
fructueuse par l'iran et les états unis
avant l'incident de natanz